We Will Understand Just Two Concepts In This
Video First Angle Bisectors In A
Triangle And Second The Point Where They Meet
First Let's Understand What An Angle
Bisector Is Considered An Angle As We Have A Ray Body That
Passes Through The Vertex And Is Between Its
Arms  If the two angles
formed are equal then re bd e e called the
angle
bisector let's erase this and look at angle
bisectors in a triangle
from triangle a s this triangle
has three angles angle a angle b and angle c
each angle will have an angle bisector  Of
its own we'll come across something really
interesting after we draw all the angle
bisectors of this
triangle let re a b the angle bisector
of angle a which would make the measure of these two
angles equal let re b b the angle
bisector of angle b  These two angles
formed would be equal Now we come to the
interesting part Let ray c be the angle
bisector of angle c and that again gives us two
equal angles What's so
interesting about this All the angle
bisectors of a triangle meet at one
single point  And yes this is true for any kind of a
triangle acute to scalene
isosceles and which ever the angle bisectors will
always meet at one point so if you are
constructing angle bisectors of a
triangle and you find that all of them
do not meet at one point  Then It Means Just One Thing You've Gone Somewhere Your
Construction Let's Name That Point Aa The
point where the three angle bisectors of a
triangle meet is called the in center but does the
in center always remain inside the triangle regardless
of the type of
Triangle Let's erase this and look at an
interesting
recording This recording is taken from
math
open.com and helps a great deal in understanding
the location of the in
center This is a triangle with all its angle
bisectors meeting at the in center to
understand the  Location of the in center with
different conditions of three angles We can
move the point a around a dozen matter if the triangle
is a right angle the in
center always remains inside the
triangle even if we move point b around the
in center will always  Remain inside and the same would
apply to point C The point i is
actually a center of a circle where does the circle lie Let's
look at this triangle as with in center
i The point i is actually the center of the
circle which touches all  The sides at just one
point so segment a is actually a tangent at this
point similarly b and s are tangent at this
point and this point respectively the in
circle is actually the largest
circle that can completely fit into
the tri angle remember the point  i is called
the in center and this circle is called the in
[music]
circle